hi everyone
i hope everyone had a great weekend and
enjoyed the
rain yesterday
um
a couple reminders homework 3 is due on
wednesday the optional homework 4 will
come out on wednesday
also for people who are remote and on
zoom
so far i think everyone has been asking
questions through chat but i wanted to
kind of have a quick reminder that
if you want to instead of asking a
question via chat you could also raise
your hand on zoom and when i call on you
we should be able to hear you verbally
if you want to ask verbal questions
cool
so today we're going to be talking about
meta reinforcement learning
and we're going to be talking about the
problem statement for meta reinforcement
learning and then we're going to be
talking about two classes of methods
black box meta rl methods and
optimization based meta-rl methods
black box meta rl methods are going to
come up in homework four
and then
on wednesday we're also going to talk
about meta rl but we're going to talk
about a specific part of the meta rl
problem statement which is learning how
to explore
um this will really be the focus of
homework four but these methods will use
kind of some of the basics in black box
meta rl
and then the goals of the lecture will
be to
really try to understand the problem
statement of meta-rl how it differs from
kind of standard metal learning as well
as understand the basics of black box
and optimization based meta rl methods
cool
so as a little bit of recap
previously we talked about reinforcement
learning algorithms as a
as kind of a primer on
a lot of what we'll talk about today we
also talked about multitask girl
and we introduced both model 3 methods
as well as model-based methods and we
kind of saw this kind of overall anatomy
of a reinforcement learning algorithm
where you
collect some data you
estimate return in some way and then you
use that to improve your behavior
and of course one of the things that's
pretty different about
i guess there's two things that are
different about rl compared to
supervised learning one is that you
collect your own data and the second is
that instead of giving getting direct
labels you're given reward feedback
and this changes how the learning
algorithm operates
and so we saw a few different ways for
estimating the return
directly through monte carlo or fitting
a value function to estimate reward as
well as just estimating the dynamics of
the environment
and then we also saw ways to use these
estimates of the return to improve your
behavior through policy gradient through
kind of taking the arc max of your value
function and also through planning with
your model
great and then
before we talked about reinforcement
learning we also talked about these
different problem settings including
multitask learning transfer learning and
meta learning
and all these different scenarios the
tasks have to share some amount of
structure
and what we'll really be looking at
today is how we can
look at the meta learning problem in a
reinforcement learning scenario where
our goal is to quickly learn a new
reinforcement learning task
given
experience from previous reinforcement
learning tasks
and one thing that's going to be
different is that instead of just given
data from these tasks we're actually
going to have to collect the data from
each of the training tasks ourselves
okay and then we saw that a
reinforcement learning task corresponds
to a markov decision process with a
state space an action space essentially
the
domain of the problem
the initial state distribution the
dynamics of how the environment evolves
over time as well as the reward function
and we saw that generally any of these
things can vary across tasks although in
general the dynamics and the reward are
often the things that are changing uh
across tasks
and so meta reinforcement learning is
essentially going to correspond to meta
learning but with reinforcement learning
tasks
and where essentially we need to collect
data from our training tasks in a way
that allows us to solve a new task
through
exploration and adaptation in that new
mdp
cool so concretely what this looks like
is before we talked about the metal
learning problem
we saw supervised learning and then we
saw how metal learning is essentially
trying to
kind of take as input a small amount of
data for a new supervised learning
problem and a new example and
leverage the data in order to
effectively predict the label for the
test example
so this was meta-supervised learning we
did this with a data set of data sets
across all of our tasks
where each data set has input output
pairs
and this view is useful because it
essentially reduces the problem of metal
learning to learning something that
takes this input a data set and makes
predictions about new examples
now in meta reinforcement learning
we're no longer going to be trying to
solve supervised learning tasks
uh instead we want to learn a policy so
our input is going to be
estate st
our policy is going to output which
action should be taken at that state
and so generally we'll be learning this
policy that maps from states to actions
um and in reinforcement learning instead
of having input output pairs
you're instead given or you still have
experience in
that mdp
that has states actions rewards and next
dates
and so we're not told directly what to
do we're just given rewards for
behaviors that
are good and we try to maximize the
rewards for those behaviors
so this should mostly be review up until
now
and in meta reinforcement learning we
want to be able to quickly solve a
reinforcement learning task
and so
it's going to be quite analogous to the
meta supervised learning scenario
but um our training data is not going to
be input output pairs it's now going to
be
experience collected in a reinforcement
learning task
and you can think of it as k episodes
from running your some policy pi
um or k rollouts from pi
and we want to be able to use k rollouts
from
some policy in order to
maximize reward in that mdp and k might
be very small
typically in reinforcement learning you
may require a lot of experience we want
to be able to solve a new task with a
very small amount of experience and so
given this experience
we then want to be able to map from
states to actions and
be able to
quickly learn how to solve a new mdp
from just these k rollouts
now the data for this um we'll again
have a data set of data sets
that's collected for each task
but one thing that will be different is
that we won't necessarily just be given
these data sets this is
the data from each of these tasks
actually has to be collected ourselves
through the
meta reinforcement learning process
okay
so now the key parts of this problem is
that we have to figure out how to design
and optimize f
uh this
we saw this uh before and actually we'll
talk a lot about this today and how this
differs a little bit in the
reinforcement learning setting
and then we also need to learn how to
collect appropriate data
so
we need to collect all of the dis we
also need to learn what
policy pi will help us collect
informative data for solving the mdp
and so essentially we need to learn how
to explore
and this is usually pretty important
because if you just run a random policy
for example that might not give you
informative information about the task
and if you have a good exploration
policy then this should allow you to
very quickly infer the task
so you both need a good exploration
strategy here as well as a good
adaptation strategy in f data
cool
and the other thing that i'll note here
is that your exploration policy pi
doesn't necessarily need to be the same
as the policy that actually adapts to
the task which is represented by f
so we can look at an example
so say we want to learn how to quickly
navigate in a new maze
so
we collected some experience
in a maze so maybe we just had one
episode so k equals one
and we collected some experience that's
shown in this directory that goes from
red eventually to blue and the goal is
to get to the
blue
box and you don't necessarily see
the agent only sees where it kind of
locally is in the maze it doesn't
actually see the whole picture of the
maze
and so
given this training data the single
episode in the mdp we want to be able to
ultimately get a policy that can then
directly go to the goal and directly
solve the mdp very quickly
so this is what we'd like to be able to
do so this would correspond to meta test
time
and then what we want to do during
metatrading is to prepare ourselves for
solving this meta test task
and so
if this is what we want to be able to do
then what we can do is we can at
mediterranean time practice solving lots
of different kinds of mazes
so we can
collect data in different tasks where
different mazes correspond to different
tasks
and learn how to solve each of these
mazes so that when we're given a new
maze at test time we can
very quickly learn how to navigate in
that maze with maybe just a single
episode
um and of course uh here the example of
different tasks corresponds to different
mazes but the different tasks could be
something different as well
yeah so the question is can you have
multiple exploration policies when
you're collecting data um when you
collect your training data in in an mdp
you um it could really
be whatever you want i i guess i listed
a single policy that could also be a
mixture of multiple different policies
such that you collect data
according to that mixture of policies
um the other thing is that the
exploration policy can also be recurrent
and so it can
incorporate its experience in the maze
so far when determining how to continue
to explore in that maze
okay and then one more note about the
meta rl problem
is that
um this is the formulation that i
discussed before i'll refer to this as
like the episodic variant of meta rl
where you're given k episodes from pi
but the training data could also be
corresponding to
um
k time steps from your policy you could
essentially learn in a
more kind of online fashion when you're
given even
less data from pi rather than k episodes
you have k time steps
and like i mentioned before the
exploration policy and adaptation policy
don't necessarily need to be the same
cool any questions on the problem
statement
so essentially what we did is we just
took the metal learning problem and
replaced the tasks with mdps
so how do we actually go about solving
this problem statement
we're going to look at two different
kinds of approaches block box approach
is an optimization based approaches
we're actually not going to
talk at all about non-parametric methods
i'm curious if anyone has thoughts on
why that's the case
or why it would be difficult to apply
non-parametric my learning methods to
meta rl
[Music]
yeah exactly so in
with non-parametric methods
they're really designed for
classification problems where you are
trying to classify among a few different
classes
in general when you're trying to predict
actions
sometimes those actions might be
continuous in which case it's more of a
regression problem and you just can't
solve it at all with with non-parametric
methods
um and even in cases where you do have a
discrete action space it isn't really
analogous to this concept of class it's
more analogous to like which of these
actions should you take
it seems possible that you could apply
non-parametric methods to meta-rl when
you have discrete actions
but that's why they haven't been used at
all because you don't really have this
notion of class and it's not really a
nearest neighbor's problem anymore it's
more a problem of using your experience
to figure out
how to solve new environments and
you can't really apply this sort of idea
of matching
or nearest neighbors to solve these
kinds of problems
okay
so we'll start with black box methods
and um
in black box meta learning before we saw
that we can essentially
take this form where we have a function
that takes us and put our data as well
as our new test input and predicts the
corresponding label
and in general the trend will
almost be the same in rl where we take
as input a data set as well as a new
state that we're observing and we're
going to predict the corresponding
action for that state
um so for example our black box model
could be a recurrent neural network
that takes as input
some of our training data seen so far
and
as well as our query data point st
and then predicts the corresponding
action
now one thing that you can note here is
that the training data is actually going
to be
getting larger over time it's
essentially going like at every single
time step we're just adding to our
training data
and so it's going to be incrementally
growing and essentially growing on a
rolling basis
where
kind of your query set at
the current time step will then actually
become part of the training data set at
the next time step
and
yeah so you can
view it as essentially a recurrent
policy it takes as input the states and
the rewards so that it can infer what
the task is
from that experience in order to figure
out what to do at the current state
so now i have a couple questions for you
one thing you might notice here is that
we're passing in the states and the
rewards but we're not passing in the
actions
um does anyone has any thoughts on why
we don't need to pass in the actions
in in with the support type
um
so you're saying that the
um
did you contribute any additional
information um
you're saying that given the state that
you transitioned into um the past
actions don't matter because of the
markov property essentially you you know
what you're
you see the state that you're in
um
and that does like that tells you
essentially about your previous action
that's
sort of right um anymore dad
yeah so the other thing is that the
policy is actually predicting the
actions itself and so its hidden state
is actually going to contain information
about the previous action
and so
because the hidden state already
contains all the information that's
needed to predict that action
then the action information is actually
already stored and you don't need to
pass it in as input again
and
one reason why that information is
important is that even just despite the
markov property it is helpful to have
those previous actions because if
different tasks vary based on different
dynamics then you actually want to know
information about sas prime about what
the dynamics are
and so it is actually important to have
that to know that action information
because it allows you to identify
differences in the dynamics
but the hidden state already captures it
because
the hidden state is what was used to
generate that action
okay
and then the other question is
how is this different from just doing
like standard reinforcement learning
with the recurrent policy
so it is quite similar to just doing
standard rl with the recurrent policy
but there are a couple differences and
i'm curious if anyone can spot any of
them
yeah so one thing is typically in
standard rl we don't pass in the
previous reward function at each time
step we just pass in the state
and so this is one thing that's
different
good
any other things that are different
so the i guess the first thing that i
had here is that the reward is passed as
input we're also training this rnn
across multiple mdps rather than within
a single mdp
and therefore the rewards might actually
this is one reason why you might need to
pass in the rewards as input
also i can note that if the rewards are
the same across tasks and the only thing
that's different is the dynamics then
you don't actually need to pass in the
reward
any other differences
so one other thing that's pretty
important is that
if you want to learn across episodes if
you want the syst this thing to kind of
take as input
incorporate a training data set that
isn't just like a single episode but
it's actually multiple episodes then
it's really important to maintain your
hidden state across different episodes
in your task
and so
one of the things that's really
different about kind of doing rl with
the standard recurrent policy is that
typically you're just going to be
maintaining your hidden state within an
episode whereas here
you're actually going to be
not resetting your hidden state at the
beginning of each episode you're only
going to be resetting at the beginning
of each task
and it's going to try to essentially
aggregate information about the task
across these different episodes
so that it can essentially gain as much
information and knowledge about the
current task as possible
yeah so this particular plot doesn't
necessarily imply it unless the dot dot
dot kind of includes um
includes additional episodes
i have another diagram that that
illustrates this more explicitly so
um here say your episodes are 10 or t
time steps long then you are going to
have an arrow that continues that hidden
state
between the boundary of t to zero
um and then once you get to the end of
the last episode you will then see this
will have two episodes if you only have
two episodes then you'll kind of cut off
at that point and then start the new
episode for the new task
um at time step zero
yeah
yeah so the question is what's the point
of having different episodes now given
that we're now kind of treating
different tasks different episodes
and
one of the things that's important here
is that s1 is going to be kind of drawn
again from the initial state
distribution and so
uh when you're exploring in your mdp it
can be helpful to kind of
sample multiple times from the initial
state distribution and so like sample
multiple possible trajectories and so
we're going to essentially have this
notion of episodes and maybe even a
notion of kind of
meta episode or trial that captures all
of the episodes within a single task
and sometimes the literature refers to
that as trial i've also seen it
sometimes referred to as meta episode
because it captures multiple episodes
within a task
yeah so the question is isn't this very
difficult to optimize because
like essentially we need to like
remember a lot and we need to
remember like all the way back from the
first episode and if you have a lot of
episodes
um
then you essentially like learning
things from the earlier episodes might
be very difficult there's a great
question uh we'll talk about this in a
slide or two but there are a couple
architectures that aren't recurrent
networks
that will
that can potentially aggregate
information
in a way that isn't like this sequential
and those kinds of architectures can
help the optimization a lot um you can
think of for example things like
transformers um or things like things
that kind of take the episode
information and then average it into a
single embedding that's going to make it
easier to back propagate into
the first episode for example
there are pros and cons to teach
approaches but some of those
architectures make it easier to optimize
cool so as an algorithm what this looks
like is we first sample a task
um
from our kind of the set of tasks that
we have
then we're going to roll out this
recurrent policy for
up to n episodes where n is basically
the kind of the horizon of the learning
problem
um and as i mentioned before this d
train is going to kind of be updated
incrementally with each time step it's
not actually it's no longer fixed it's
actually growing online
then
this will be under the dynamics and the
reward for task
i and then we'll store
the data that we collected in some
replay buffer for that task
and then we can update the policy by
sampling data from that replay buffer to
essentially just max like
optimize this recurrent policy so that
it maximizes reward over all of your
tasks
um and this this last step can be done
with a variety of different
learning algorithms it could be done
with policy gradients it could be done
with um
with uh like q learning based methods
for example as well
um
so i was trying to keep this general in
the sense that it can be applied with a
few different approaches and then of
course you also repeat this process once
you update your policy you'll then
collect data
for another task and so on and so forth
yeah
okay is it important for the reward
functions between tasks to be sort of in
the same
magnitude for the values
yeah
so the question is um does is important
for the word function to be in the same
value for different tasks
in general this is quite important
because
if they are on very different magnitudes
then when you do this last step it's
going to care a lot more about the task
that has a higher magnitude reward
than about tasks that have lower
magnitude rewards
and so if you want it to ultimately be
able to adapt to all of the tasks in the
task distribution you generally want
them to have similar magnitudes
cool
okay so that's what happens at
metatrading time and then once you learn
this kind of recurrent policy that can
learn how to adapt to a task then at
meta test time you're given a new task
and you simply just take the policy
that you learned and roll out that
policy
for kind of the horizon of the learning
problem
generally you don't want to
roll it out for more than n episodes
because if you roll out an rnn for
example for longer than the horizon that
it was trained that it may not perform
well um although one thing that you
could do is something something where
you try to freeze the behavior um that
you get at episodes and no longer update
that policy and just keep on writing
that policy
but if you do really care about like
learning for end episodes and then
continuing to kind of execute that
policy you can also optimize for that
behavior during metatrading
okay um and then
to touch a little bit on architectures
and optimizers for this um
the approach of using black box matter
url is quite general but you can there's
of course lots of different design
choices you can choose
so
one of the first
approaches for this is referred to as rl
squared because they're trying to do
fast reinforcement learning via slow
reinforcement learning and they
essentially
did exactly what we talked about on the
previous slide where they had this
recurrent neural network that takes as
input
states and and rewards and is able to
predict the
the next action
and
in these two papers they used policy
gradient methods trpo and a3c
um
instead of using your current neural
network you can also use an
attention-based architecture that has
kind of connections from the current
time step all the way back to that first
time step
and these methods are going to be
better at
kind of
propagating across very long sequences
this particular architecture was
alternating between attention and 1d
convolutions but you could also have
like a purely attention-based
architecture as well
and then they were again optimizing the
policy with trpo which is a policy
gradient method
and then the last architecture that i'll
mention is
something more analogous to
an architecture that we saw before where
we essentially encode all of our
transitions
into a
into some embedding and then we average
that in vetting
and then pass that average embedding
into our q function and into our policy
um and so this was kind of more of like
a feed forward architecture than average
um and then the actual optimizer that
was used with soft actor critic which is
a value-based reinforcement learning
method
and
you can note that there's a q function
and a policy here and that's kind of
indicative of the
fact that it's a value-based method
yeah so the question is how do you
choose the the reinforcement learning
optimization um like there's a reason
why multiple of these use trpo um
the
i guess uh we'll talk about this in a
second too but the
i guess things like policy gradients are
quite simple
and um like quite simple to implement
and are
also pretty easy to get to work um
if you give it enough data
uh and so i think that these were like
two of the first meta rl
black box meta url methods to come out
and so usually going with simple things
that are kind of easier to get to work
that don't require quite as much tuning
is helpful for that um that said methods
that are on policy tend to be very data
inefficient
and so these methods are also extremely
data-hungry during the meta training
process
um and so that's uh that's a reason not
to use like policy gradient-based
methods and a reason to favor
value-based methods
yeah so in in practice you will sample a
mini batch of tasks on task one so the
question is is the reason why we're just
sampling one task here um in practice
you will actually sample a mini batch
rather than just one task and then
you'll do this update on that mini batch
of tasks
so
you won't roll it out for
so if you have
um
k tasks and n episodes in your batch
then
you're not going to roll it out for k
times n because you need to break the
rnn state at the boundary of each task
and so you'll roll it you can
essentially roll it out in parallel
for
each of the k tasks
um and so you will eventually get uh
the data that you'll get will be k times
n um episodes
but you do want to make sure that you
cut the hidden state at the at the task
boundary so that it's only aggregating
information about that task and not
about the previous tasks
um
yeah so yeah and in general um i wrote
it as one task for kind of to make the
notation simple but in practice you will
want to use a mini batch of tasks
um
also if this sometimes this policy
update it can be with that mini batch it
can also just sample directly from the
replay buffer
and so it doesn't necessarily need to
include the data that you just collected
okay so
i guess one other note about
architectures is that um this is
actually just doing feed forward and
averaging over individual transitions
you can also
um
do an rnn over transitions within an
episode and then average across episodes
so you could sort of potentially like
mix and match different components here
okay so let's look at a couple examples
of what these algorithms do
so the first example will actually be
just the maze navigation example that i
talked about before
where we want to be able to learn how to
navigate a maze
and we're going to train on a thousand
different small mazes
and then we're going to evaluate the
algorithm's ability to quickly learn how
to solve new mazes both small mazes and
large mazes
cool and then
after the kind of meta training process
we'll look at some videos of what it can
do at meta test time
and so here's a video this is showing
the first person point of view this is
showing kind of a top-down view of what
the agent is doing
this is the kind of
the first episode
of
the um
the first episode at meta test time
where it's essentially exploring the
maze and looking
at different
different parts of it and then this is
the second episode where it just goes
straight to the goal
um and so we can
probably just try to play that again so
here's the first episode where it's
exploring
this is essentially to try to understand
the mdp or the maze that it's in
and then it's incrementally kind of
updating the hidden state of the rnn
based on the training data that it's
seen so far
and then at the end of this episode it's
going to keep its hidden state
the same
and then use a policy that can adapt to
the exploration episode that it
collected in order to go straight to the
goal
the system can also work on larger mazes
as well so here's a here's an example of
a large maze where it
is currently exploring
in the maze in the first episode
i'm still exploring and then
it sees the goal here
and then
after that episode
it can very quickly
go directly to the goal
so both of these are held out mazes that
it hadn't seen during training
and
in some ways you can think of the first
episode as the support set and the
second episode as the query set
but in this case it is actually also
just like trying to run things online as
well
um so
yeah
um and then in terms of quantitative
results uh the this is comparing
um
using an lstm versus using the kind of
the mixture of attention and conflares
it's also comparing to just a random
policy
and what we see is um
i think this is evaluating the um
the number of time steps that are needed
to reach the goal in each episode
and so the first thing that we see is
that um
the random isn't doing very well
um we also see that generally it takes
longer to find the goal in the large
maze than the small maze
and then generally we see that it's able
to more quickly find the goal in episode
two than in episode one because it's
leveraging kind of the exploration that
it did in episode one in order to find
the goal in episode two more quickly
any questions on this
and one thing i didn't show here is the
metatrading process itself those videos
were just from meta test time and during
metatrading time it was essentially
doing that same sort of kind of two
episode process but across all of these
different mazes in its mediterranean set
and so it's kind of learning how to
explore and solve these mazes so that
when it's given a new maze
it can quickly
solve that maze
[Music]
if anything yeah so what is the learners
sharing across
um mazes so one thing that you can see
is that because it's doing better in
episode two than in episode one it is
clearly
storing information in its hidden state
that tells it about that maze
as it's going to basically be encoding
something about the geometry of the maze
um i don't think that they did any sort
of visualization in the paper about what
um
whether it's storing the full geometry
or just storing like the solution path
for example to the goal
um but that something like that could be
interesting to visualize
did you ever watch
yeah
distribution but in this case i feel
like the large mazes have come out
from different distributions with a
small meeting so
by the same assumption on your business
yeah so a great question the question is
um we assumed before that the kind of
mediterranean tasks and the meta test
tests are the same
um
it seems like now when we're testing on
large mazes there's actually this
mismatch
um
so in general we generally still need to
make the same assumption that training
and testing tasks are from the same
distribution
um
qualitatively they found that the larger
mazes were similar enough that it was
still able to generalize
i expect that if you gave it like a maze
that was 10 times as large it probably
wouldn't work
one reason why it might be generalizing
well is that it is still a first person
observation and so the data that it's
seeing is still going to be very similar
between the training the test tasks the
like for example the quarters are the
same size the visuals are generally the
same
um
and so it is nice that it's able to
generalize it's also possible that in
cases where there's a longer path
towards the goal
maybe those are the scenarios where it's
not able to do as well whereas if it's
in a larger maze but there's still a
small path to the goal maybe it's still
able to do well because it saw a smaller
path to the goal during training
yeah
um
yeah so the question is um what kind of
what is the support set in the query set
and like what policy are we using for to
getting the support set and what policy
are we using to get the query set
so
um you could essentially like you can
think of it as support set being episode
one and queries that being episode two
um in reality it is more like a rolling
online basis where the support set is
all the time steps you've seen so far
and the query set is the current time
step
um and so you're actually going to be
trading on support sets that have lots
of different sizes
um and then in terms of what policy that
you're using
um and this work is actually using the
same policy for collecting the first
episode and the second episode which is
just this recurrent neural network that
takes his input some hidden state that
encodes the support set scene so far
um
and that said in practice they could be
different policies and
and we'll especially see in the next
lecture
on wednesday there are scenarios where
you want them to be different policies
so
as a kind of an example of that say in
the mazes
say they're on one of the walls there's
actually a map that like shows the
layout of the maze in that setting in
the first episode you want to just go
look at the map you don't want to like
go figure it out
um and so you want a policy that looks
at the map for exploration and then uses
that information from the map in order
to solve the task
and so in scenarios like that you often
do want different like pretty different
policies
yeah
i have been feeling like these
black boxes
especially
but of course imagine it's way more
complicated
[Music]
it seems like this is going to work
decently well with on policy methods but
it's going to be a lot more complicated
for off policy methods like like dqn or
like you learning based methods that
what you're asking
yeah so there have been successful
instances of people training q learning
algorithms with recurrent neural
networks that have kind of an online
update
um
that said generally recurrent policies
are pretty difficult to optimize with
q-learning
and there are just a couple tricks that
that people use there's this paper
called r2d2 that shows that if you
essentially store the hidden states in
the buffer rather than recomputing the
hidden states that actually works a lot
better
um
that said it does get more complicated
with value based methods and um
i can actually show one example of
value-based methods maybe before getting
to the other question
so
in particular we want to be able to use
value-based methods because they're a
lot more efficient
this paper is going to look not at
navigation problems but at continuous
control problems
where you might want the agent to run in
different directions or
at different velocities or be able to
adapt to different physical dynamics
um
and so
in general reinforcement learning
algorithms are very efficient at meta
test time they can solve the task in
like two episodes but what's challenging
is the meta training process might be
very inefficient with things like policy
gradients and so what we'd love to do is
to use value-based methods or off-policy
methods during meta training in order to
optimize for the black box approach
um
and so i guess
maybe i gave this one away but you would
expect off policy meta rl to be much
more efficient than on policy meta rl
because these meta-rl methods are going
to inherit the sample complexity of the
algorithm they're using to optimize the
meta-learning process
um
and so essentially what this
what this worked is it used the kind of
feed forward and average architecture in
order to compute a context
just like i showed on the previous slide
and it fed that context into both the
policy and into the critic
and it found that if you did something
like that
you are able to actually solve these
metal rl tasks
much more efficiently than all policy
methods and so
what these plots are showing is the
x-axis is the amount of meta training
time steps and the y-axis is how well
you're able to
adapt and
the blue curve is is this algorithm that
uses uh that builds upon a value based
on all methods soft factor critic
and all the other methods are using
policy gradient um
and so you see that there's kind of this
pretty huge difference in sample
efficiency
the on policy methods their asymptotic
performance is shown with the dashed
line and so we see that asymptotically
they do actually do pretty well but the
time it takes for them to learn is much
much slower than value-based oral
methods
does that answer your question
cool did you have a question in the box
no
cool um and then
one uh
short digression is that we've talked
about black box
methods and these actually look somewhat
similar to multi-task policies
um so
for example in a multi-task learning
policy we'll be conditioning on a task
identifier
so for example maybe we have a robot we
want to stack in different locations
z might be the location where we should
stack
or maybe we want to walk in different
directions and zi would encode the
direction that we want to walk
um
when we have these
these black box metal learning methods
you can essentially
view the data or the experience as the
task identifier that you're passing into
the model
um and so it's sort of like the same
thing as multitaskrl except where
experience is identifying helping you
identify the task rather than an
explicit identifier
and then of course you
have to figure out how to explore
to collect information like that and
then
the
the policy the multi-task policy is kind
of the last part of that network
so essentially like a multitask policy
with your experience as a task
identifier
we've also previously talked a lot about
goal condition policies and value
functions
one thing that's nice about meta rl is
that rewards are essentially like kind
of a strict generalization of goals
goals can specify reaching certain
states whereas rewards can specify all
sorts of behaviors including reaching
certain states
and so
really the meta-r objective is allowing
you to adapt to new tasks from rewards
for that task whereas
goal-conditioned rl's allowing you to
generalize to
retain new goals
you can also think of this as k-shot
adaptation versus zero shot
generalization
yeah
um
[Music]
the question is in the maze example um
what was the reward function um was it
only like reaching a goal or does it
account for the time it takes to
reach the goal um
i don't know exactly what they used
there are a few different choices one
could just be like one for reaching the
goal in zero not for reaching the goal
and if you have a discount factor that's
less than one then it's going to
encourage you to try to reach the goal
faster
another thing that might be common to do
is to use a positive reward for reaching
the goal and a small negative reward for
every time step in which you haven't
reached the goal and that will also
encourage it to get there faster
the last thing that you could do is you
could give it a shaped reward that
indicates the distance to the goal
that is something that you could also
use although
that's going to give it a lot more
information about where the goal is and
whether it's getting closer or further
to the goal it's more like a game of hot
cold than um than actually trying to
navigate and find where a certain object
is
um on that note the other thing that i
could mention is that the rewards that
you use in your support set that you
feed into the network
those could actually be a different
reward function than the one you use to
optimize
and so one thing that you could do
that's kind of cool is give it a very
sparse reward that it has to learn from
in the support set but then train your
medi train to have your whole
mediterranean process with more of a
shaped reward and then you can
essentially learn how to um explore and
solve sparks forward tasks using
more dense rewards during metatrading
okay so to summarize black box meta rl
these methods are quite general and
quite expressive
there's of course a variety of design
choices in the architecture
um
and they're generally pretty easy to
combine with different
rl optimizers
essentially you'll kind of optimize yeah
optimize the behavior either with
respect to some bellman error objective
like eq learning or with respect to
policy gradients
um they do tend to be
somewhat difficult to optimize like
we've talked about especially with
recurrent networks you have to back
propagate through this long string of
time steps
um also in general you are like in black
box metal learning you're learning how
to learn from scratch you're not
building any structure into the meta
learner and so this also makes it
difficult to optimize
and then like we saw before it's in
terms of the data efficiency it's going
to inherit its data efficiency from the
outer rl optimizer that's used and so if
you use policy gradients it's going to
be very data inefficient and if you use
value-based rl it's going to be probably
a lot more efficient
okay any questions on blackbox meta are
all before we move on to optimization
based methods
cool um so
uh
like we just talked about black box
metal learning methods
can be difficult to optimize and so one
thing that might make it easier is to
build in the structure of optimization
into the metal learner
um
and so if we want to turn this kind of
approach into a meta-rl algorithm
we have a few different choices for
doing this
and in particular one of the choices we
have is
what sort of optimization should we use
in
the inner loop of this optimization
um as a kind of
a few possible choices we could use
policy gradients
um we could use q learning
or we could also use something like
model based rl
i'm curious if anyone has thoughts on
kind of
what some of the trade-offs might be for
using these different approaches in the
inner loop irrespective of what you do
in the outer loop
yeah
i guess from what we discussed earlier
since
policy is
type of approach
yeah so policy gradients can be very
uh sample and efficient and so that
might be a reason not to use them in the
inner loop
[Music]
yeah so if you
if your state space is very large and
you're trying to like solve the maze
navigation example
um for example then your model may
actually be very inaccurate if your
support set doesn't cover the entire
relevant part of the state space
yeah so if the tasks all have the same
dynamics but have different rewards then
you can actually just use a single model
and you don't actually need to adapt the
model um and so
using mammal with model based style
probably makes the most sense when the
dynamics are changing across tasks
any other points
cool so um those are all great points um
i'll overview some of the kind of
trade-offs and why we might use one of
these versus the other in mammal so
with policy gradients one thing that's
nice is that they are
very clearly gradient based they very
clearly give you a gradient and so that
makes it nice to
apply a gradient in the inner loop
um they are on policy and so this means
that they are going to be inefficient
um the other thing that's maybe a little
bit more subtle about policy gradients
is that they don't actually carry that
much information
especially when you have sparse rewards
so say for example
um you're maybe in the maze navigation
example or you're just trying to kind of
learn something about the dynamics about
the structure of the dynamics in the
environment
then if you look at the policy gradient
if you remember it looks something like
the gradient of
log pi
summed over your time steps
it looks something like this times the
sum of rewards for those time steps
and if you're trying to learn something
about the dynamics
and you end up maybe maybe you're in the
maze navigation example and you collect
a trajectory
and
you didn't get to the goal so you got a
reward of zero
then that means that
this is going to be zero
and then your entire gradient is going
to be zero
and that's really unfortunate because
that means you're not going to get any
information about the dynamics of the
environment
if you didn't get any reward
and so this is one reason why policy
gradients can be pretty difficult with
with an algorithm like mammal um it's
because that you want that integrated to
be very informative about the task
and whenever you're in a sparse reward
setting and you don't get any rewards
it's not going to tell you any
information
about the task
and about the environment
so it can work well with shaped words
but if you have sparse rewards it can be
rather problematic
yeah
yeah so if you um
you can reward shaping will certainly
help and that will give you a lot more
information
if you give it like a negative reward
for everything um
uh like maybe this is kind of a fixed
concept of like negative t because maybe
you give it a reward of negative one at
every time step this still isn't going
to be that informative because um
it's uh
for um
four different episodes like it's not
going to tell you essentially which
episodes are better than the other
um
if you're just getting a reward of
negative t for all of your episodes
cool um so those are kind of the pros
and cons of policy gradients
um
now for key learning
um
learning actually isn't gradient based
it's key learning is more like a lot
like dynamic programming
and if you look at the update for q
learning it is
[Music]
it's something like uh kind of
q hat of s a you're trying to make this
match
i guess if you look at the loss function
at something like
um
the reward plus gamma times
max of
a prime
of q of s prime a prime
something like that and one thing that
you might notice is if you take a single
gradient step
on
this
objective then this is only going to
propagate kind of one time step of
information
because this is um
the state and action at the next time
step this is the statement actually at
the current time step
and so
a single gradient update isn't going to
give you a lot of global information
about the task it's only going to give
you very local information
at a particular time step
and as a result this means that
to get a good
kind of update for
your like inner loop you're going to
need a lot of steps to propagate
information
from the future to the current step
and as a result it could actually be
very difficult to use q learning in the
inner loop
unless you take a very large number of
steps but then you have to also back
propagate through that very large number
of steps in the inner loop
it is going to be off policy so it's
going to be more data efficient um that
said there's been very few successful
examples of optimization-based
q-learning meta-learning methods
okay and then one last example is for
model based rl uh
learning a model if you want to kind of
adapt to different dynamics
model based rl is just a supervised
learning problem on the model and so
updates to your model are going to be
gradient based
it's also you can do this in an off
policy way and so it can also be data
efficient
this makes the most sense when you have
a more local update and when you
have varying dynamics across tasks
but it does
address some of the shortcomings that we
see in policy gradients in q-learning
okay
so
at a high level essentially optimization
based meta rl
can look like embedding and optimization
where you choose different objectives
for the inner loop and different
objectives for the outer loop
next i'll just go through two
instantiations of optimization based
metaurl so we can look at some kind of
concrete examples of actually
implementing these algorithms
um so the first thing that we'll look at
is mammal with policy gradients
like we mentioned it can be a terrible
choice if you have sparse rewards
although it can still be reasonable if
you have shaped rewards and plenty of
data
so
here's kind of
to help us uh kind of remember the
objectives here's the mammal objective
here is the policy gradient objective
which is hopefully the same as what i
wrote here i guess there's also kind of
an expectation with respect to pi theta
and so what the meta training process
looks like is we will
sample a task
we'll then
collect data by rolling out our policy
pi theta
this is the policy according to our set
of initial parameters
then for the inner loop adaptation we're
going to compute a policy gradient using
those rollouts
by computing
this objective
or sorry this is this is just the
gradient so by computing the gradient
then we're going to
collect data by rolling out our adapted
policy
and this will be used so that we can
compute the
um the policy gradient with respect to
that of that adapted policy
um
and so each of these cases we're going
to be using a policy grading both for
the inner loop and a policy gradient for
the outer loop objective
is
yeah the question is like
for this step two is there any benefit
from using your current policy versus um
a random policy
um or some other policy so
the um
i guess the reason why we might want to
use pi theta here is that
for this to be like the correct policy
gradient
your trajectory should be drawn from pi
theta
and if it's drawn from another policy
then this gradient isn't going to be
accurate
or as accurate it's certainly not going
to be consistent it's not going to be
something that you will use to like
ultimately improve your policy and so if
you do use pi theta here then you are
kind of
more guaranteed that this gradient is
going to be
pointing in the right direction
um
there are like slightly more off policy
policy gradient methods like ppo um and
in those cases you can potentially
use older policies to collect this um
but in general it's going to be
cleaner to use your current policy
one downside that you might notice here
is we are doing these two steps of
collection and um
and this is going to get pretty um
like sample expensive in terms of sample
efficiency
and um it's one i guess one thing that
i'll also notice is we we you talked
about like policy gradient being sample
and efficient in the inner loop because
we have to also roll out pi theta and
every iteration this means it's also
sample and efficient at the outer loop
as well like at the level of the metal
learning process
i should also mention that there is uh
this is of course an iterative process
so do you still pass previous reward
into the policy um in this case no the
policy is is just a policy that maps
from states to actions
and the way that we're going to infer
the task is through the parameters of
that policy rather than passing the
rewards as input
of course you could also imagine hybrid
methods that are kind of both recurrent
and do this sort of gradient-based
adaptation um
although it kind of in the kind of
standard optimization based algorithm
we're just
updating the parameters rather than
passing in the rewards
cool and then so the result of this
process is going to be a set of initial
parameters such that
if you explore with those parameters and
fine-tune those parameters you should be
able to solve new tasks
and so what meta test time looks like
is we
are given a new task
we collect data
for that new task by rolling out our
policy with our trained meta parameters
and then we're going to adapt our policy
by running policy gradient
yeah
um good question so the question is um
so pi theta we actually want two things
from pi theta uh we want it to be good
at exploration and we want it to be good
so that if we run gradient descent it
gives us good parameters um so we are
actually asking a fair amount from pi
theta
and so the question was
uh are we actually training it for that
first thing are we trying to be good at
exploration
so
the
in some ways it really depends on how
you actually compute this outer loop
update so if you're thinking about
taking the gradient with respect to
theta
of your adapted parameters there are two
places where that comes in
one is of course like
in the like the log pi thing which you
can which will be very similar to the
supervised case the other is actually in
this expectation
um
and uh
and so ultimately you would like to back
propagate into this expectation
some implementations of the algorithm
will kind of ignore this
and in those settings it will not
actually be learning how to explore very
well it's going to assume that whatever
parameters are good for adaptation are
also good for exploration which
may be true if you have dense enough
rewards in many cases it also won't be
true
um there are also approaches that try to
estimate
to try to essentially
figure out how to back propagate into
this and incorporate the gradient with
respect to this part
into the objective
and those algorithms
can lead to a better exploration process
um
and so one example of an algorithm that
does that if you're interested in
learning more is called um
pro mp
and it was written by ignaci clavera
happy to send a reference after class
cool um
one of the things that uh
so i guess
we'll look at an illustration of this
and in particular we'll look at the task
of running in different directions for
this
quadruped simulated quadruped
um
and so first we can look at the policy
with respect to the trained better
parameters with respect to the
initialization
and this policy
um this is actually with a variant of
the algorithm that mostly ignored this
um and so it's just trying to execute a
policy that will allow it to adapt in a
single step
you end up getting a policy that looks
like this that is essentially kind of
running in place and so it seems like
it's ready to
be able to run in any given direction
because this is a dense reward task this
sort of exploration is actually
sufficient for figuring out which
direction it should run in
so then if you take a single gradient
step with respect to the task of running
backward
you get a policy that looks like this
so it's able to
um
in the single gradients that adapt this
behavior pretty significantly
and then if you take a single gradient
step with respect to the task of running
forward you get a policy that looks like
this
uh so we again see that it's able to
kind of pretty successfully adapt its
behavior
at least in cases where you have these
dense rewards
cool so
that was an example of mammal with
policy gradients
we see that it can solve these uh
kind of these simple
scenarios um when you have dense rewards
the mediterranean process for this was
quite slow and we actually saw that in
some of the plots that came before
now let's look at kind of one more
concrete instantiation of mammal in meta
rl
and in this case we're going to be
looking at
model based ro
and we're going to be looking at a
scenario where only the dynamics are
changing across tasks
um we're also going to be looking at
an online variant and so in particular
in those previous videos we saw like
you're collecting some episodes and then
adapting from those episodes and then
getting a new policy
in this case we're actually going to be
our support set will just be in terms of
time steps not in terms of episodes
great so what we want to be able to do
at meta test time is we want to be able
to
adapt a model of the environment
to the last k time steps
of experience
and so
um for example if we were kind of um
if we were kind of running around on
different terrains for example we want
to take the last k time steps of our
experience of running and use that to
adapt our model to
um kind of our
the kind of current dynamics of the
environment
and then once we have this adapted model
then we can just run planning
to figure out some actions that will
accomplish some reward
so this is what we want to be able to do
at meta test time
um and this the adaptation process and
step one is just going to correspond to
fine-tuning to running a few steps of
gradient descent
and then during meta training
what we can do is we can
collect a bunch of experience using
planning using a random policy and so
forth
and
the support set will be kind of k time
steps of state action pairs
this will be d train
and then
the query set will just be the next k
time steps of experience
and so um
once once we essentially have all of our
experience collected in some way then we
can construct these support sets and
query sets just by looking at kind of
kind of chunks of data chunks of
contiguous time steps and use the first
part the first k time steps is the
support set and the next k time steps is
the query set
so essentially different tasks
are going to correspond to different
dynamics um but it's just going to
assume that the dynamics are locally
consistent
and these different tasks will end up
kind of in practice being different
windows in time
um and so if um if for example you're
running on different terrains and for
like one day you're running on one
terrain a different day you're running
on a different terrain then this will
basically create lots of different tasks
um from those different terrains
yeah
does not have to be the same
yeah yeah it doesn't have to be the same
actually in this is actually h for the
query set and k for the the support set
um you want the support set size to be
the same as what you're going to be
doing at test time
um but the query site set can be can be
different um you could choose it to be
larger in order to get more signal you
can also choose it to be smaller if you
think that your dynamics are changing
very frequently
cool and so
[Music]
with this we'll essentially be running
the same mammal objective except we'll
be using a loss function of that
corresponds to how well your model is
predicting the next state given the
current state in action
and then i can kind of if it's helpful i
can explicitly write that out so
um
the loss function will be
for task i will be something like
uh
f
of
s a minus s prime
um and this will be
sampled over
um kind of state action next state for a
particular task
so this is the loss function for
a particular task and then the mammal
objective will be the same as what we
saw before where we adapt our model
with respect to the
um
with respect to the loss function for a
given task
on some
set of data for that task
this is what we want to be able to do at
test time when we're fine two-year model
and then we're going to be
optimizing for the initial set of model
parameters such that this process works
well
and so
we can write this as kind of evaluating
how well this model does
on kind of held out data
from the next k time steps
and so then we'll be minimizing this
with respect to our initial model
parameters
okay um and then we'll we can look at
some examples of actually running this
um on where we're running on different
terrains um or running with different
dynamics
and first we'll just look at a very
simple baseline which is only doing
model based rl
and what i mean by that is we're going
to try to fit a single model to all of
the different dynamics that the agent is
encountering during training
and then at test time we'll run planning
with respect to
that single model
and if we do that in this first example
one of the joints of the robot becomes
disabled and training a single model
across those different dynamics doesn't
perform very well
and likewise
in the second example these different
platforms have different damping kind of
like a dock
and it isn't able to learn a single
model that can model the damping and the
dynamics of the robot
then if you instead
run this meta learning approach
where
you run mammal learn initial set of
model parameters with your last k time
substitute experience you adapt your
model parameters and plan with respect
to those adapted parameters
then you get something that can actually
do pretty well and it's actually
you don't actually see where the
adaptation is happening because it's
happening basically in real time
where it's taking the last k time steps
adapting its model with those lost k
time steps and planning under that
adapted model and it's doing that at
every single time step
cool um and
because this is not policy gradients um
because it is a
model based rl um it's quite efficient
during meta training time and so this is
a learning curve that's showing
how fast is learning as a function of
the metatrading time steps
the yellow curve is showing mammal with
policy gradients
and the green curve is showing
mammal with model-based arrow
and so this illustrates kind of the
difference in sample efficiency
um and this means you can also run it on
like a real robot for example so we can
collect data on
different terrains
this robot is essentially like hand
built and it
the dynamics are pretty different for
different terrains um also for different
robots
and then evaluate on different scenarios
so
one of the scenarios you can evaluate on
is take off the front right leg of the
robot which changes the dynamics pretty
significantly
and then compare the behavior just with
model based rl
compared to mammal and with model based
rl we see that it kind of struggles to
walk along the straight line it falls
off to the right
whereas with
by adapting the model to the latest
dynamics
at each time step it's able to more
effectively kind of stay on that
straight line
yeah so it is um it's essentially
learning an average dynamics model and
that's also not adapting that model um
and so you would expect that um the
average dynamics model isn't going to be
very good because trying to cover a
pretty broad distribution
and also because it's not adapting um
it's also not going to be able to kind
of specialize for any given dynamics
you could also try to like learn this
average and then adapt it
in general that also doesn't work well
because it's not actually trained such
that like adapting it with k-time steps
would work well typically you probably
need much more data in order to
effectively adapt or fine-tune the model
okay so to recap the two kinds of meta
rl methods that we talked about um
blockbox and optimization based
blockbox methods are quite general and
expressive
there's also a variety of design choices
in the architecture and the objective
they tend to be
more difficult to optimize
in optimization-based meta-rl you're
building in the inductive bias of things
like policy gradients or gradients with
respect to your model which is nice but
it is relatively easy to combine with
policy grades and model based methods
that said policy gradients are very
noisy
and it's also very difficult to combine
this with value-based rl methods
um
also one thing that i'll note about the
very top point right here about the kind
of building in this optimization
um into the model
is that
unlike in supervised learning
in rl we don't actually have
as good of optimizers for rl and so the
seductive bias becomes less valuable as
a result and so i would say that in
general one i think that black box
methods are generally more popular
especially with model free rl
um and then both these methods are going
to inherit the sample efficiency of the
outer oral optimizer
okay
great so that's a recap um and uh that
was most of the plan for today uh
next time
so today we cover the basics next time
we're going to be talking a lot about
learning how to explore essentially how
do we learn
a policy theta such that when we explore
with that policy it gives us a lot of
information about the task
and then a couple other reminders is
that homework three will be due on
wednesday and then the optional homework
four will go out on wednesday